The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Thermodynamics,
all right, let's start.
Thermodynamics is the science
of the flow of heat.
So, thermo is heat,
and dynamics is
the motion of heat.
Thermodynamics was developed
largely beginning in the
1800's, at the time of the
Industrial Revolution.
So, taming of steel.
The beginning of generating
power by burning fossil fuels.
The beginning of the problems
with CO2 and [NOISE OBSCURES]
global warming.
In fact, it's interesting
to note that the first
calculation on the impact of CO2
on climate was done in the
late 1800's by Arrhenius.
Beginning of a generation of
power moving heat from fossil
fuels to generating energy,
locomotives, etcetera.
So, he calculated what would
happen to this burning of
fossil fuels, and he decided
in his calculation, he
basically got the calculation
right, by the way, but he came
out that in 2,000 years from
the time that he did the
calculations, humans would
be in trouble.
Well, since his calculation,
we've had an exponential
growth in the amount of CO2,
and if you go through the
calculations of -- people have
done these calculations
throughout times since
Arrhenius, the time that we're
in trouble, 2,000 years and the
calculation, has gone like
this, and so now we're
really in trouble.
That's for a different
lecture.
So, anyway, thermodynamics dates
from the same period as
getting fossil fuels
out of the ground.
It's universal.
It turns out everything around
us moves energy around in one
way or the other.
If you're a biological system,
you're burning calories,
burning ATP.
You're creating heat.
If you're a warm-blooded
animal.
You need energy to move your
arms around and move around --
mechanical systems, obviously,
cars, boats, etcetera.
And even in astrophysics, when
you talk about stars, black
holes, etcetera, you're
moving energy around.
You're moving heat around when
you're changing matter through
thermodynamics.
And the cause of some
thermodynamics have even been
applied to economics, systems
out of equilibrium, like big
companies like Enron, you
know, completely out of
equilibrium, crash and burn.
You can apply non-equilibrium
thermodynamics to economics.
It was developed before
people knew
about atoms and molecules.
So it's a science that's
based on macroscopic
properties of matter.
Since then, since we know about
atoms and molecules now,
we can rationalize the concepts
of thermodynmamics
using microscopic properties,
and if you are going to take
5.62, that's what you'd
learn about.
You'd learn about statistical
mechanics, and how the
atomistic concepts rationalize
thermodynamics.
It doesn't prove it, but it
helps to getting more
intuition about the
consequences of
thermodynamics.
So it applies to macroscopic
systems that are in
equilibrium, and how to go from
one equilibrium state to
another equilibrium state, and
it's entirely empirical in its
foundation.
People have done experiments
through the ages, and they've
accumulated the knowledge from
these experiments, and they've
synthesized these experiments
into a few basic empirical
rules, empirical laws,
which are the laws of
thermodynamics.
And then they've taken these
laws and added a structure of
math upon it, to build this
edifice, which is a very solid
edifice of thermodynamics
as a science
of equilibrium systems.
So these empirical observations
then are
summarized into four laws.
So, these laws are, they're
really depillars.
They're not proven, but
they're not wrong.
They're very unlikely
to be wrong.
Let's just go through these
laws, OK, very quickly.
There's a zeroth law The zeroth
law every one of these
laws basically defines the
quantity in thermodynamics and
then defines the concept.
The zeroth law defines
temperature.
That's a fairly common-sense
idea, but it's important to
define it, and I call that
the common-sense law.
So this is the common-sense
law.
The first law ends up defining
energy, which we're going to
call u, and the concept of
energy conservation, energy
can't be lost or gained.
And I'm going to call this the
you can break even law; you
can break even law.
You don't lose energy, you
can't gain energy.
You break even.
The second law is going to
define entropy, and is going
to tell us about the direction
of time, something that
conceptually we, clearly,
understand, but is going to
put a mathematical foundation
on which way does time go.
Clearly, if I take a chalk
like this one here, and I
throw it on the ground, and it
breaks in little pieces, if I
run the movie backwards, that
doesn't make sense, right?
We have a concept of time
going forward in
a particular way.
How does entropy play into
that concept of time?
And I'm going to call this the
you can break even at zero
degrees Kelvin law.
You can only do it at
zero degrees Kelvin.
The third law is going to give
a numerical value to the
entropy, and the third law is
going to be the depressing
one, and it's going to say, you
can't get to zero degrees.
These laws are universally
valid.
They cannot be circumvented.
Certainly people have tried
to do that, and every year
there's a newspaper story, Wall
Street Journal, or New
York Times about somebody that
has invented the device that
somehow goes around the second
law and makes more energy than
it creates, and this is going
to be -- well, first of all,
for the investors this is going
to make them very, very
rich, and for the rest of us,
it's going to be wonderful.
And they go through these
arguments, and they find
venture money to fund the
company, and they get very
famous people to endorse
them, etcetera.
But you guys know, because you
have MIT degrees, and you've,
later, and you've taken 5.60,
that can't be the case, and
you're not going to get fooled
into investing money into
these companies.
But it's amazing, that every
year you find somebody coming
up with a way of going around
the second law and somehow
convincing people who are very
smart that this will work.
So, thermo is also a big tease,
as you can see from my
descriptions of these
laws here.
It makes you believe, initially,
in the feasibility
of perfect efficiency.
The first law is very upbeat.
It talks about the conservation
of energy.
Energy is conserved in
all of its forms.
You can take heat energy and
convert it to work energy and
vice versa, and it doesn't say
anything about that you have
to waste heat if you're going
to transform heat into work.
It just says it's energy.
It's all the same
thing, right?
So, you could break even if you
were very clever about it,
and that's pretty neat.
So, in a sense, it says, you
know, if you wanted to build a
boat that took energy out of the
warmth of the air, to sail
around the world,
you can do that.
And then the second law comes
in and says well, that's not
quite right.
The second law says, yes, energy
is pretty much the same
in all this form, but if you
want to convert one form of
energy into another, if you
want to convert work, heat
into work, with 100% efficiency,
you've got to go
down to zero degrees Kelvin, to
absolute zero if you want
to do that.
Otherwise you're going to
waste some of that heat
somewhere along the way,
some of that energy.
All right, so you can't get
perfect efficiency, but at
least if you were able to go to
zero degrees Kelvin, then
you'd be all set.
You just got to find a good
refrigerator on your boat, and
then you can still go
around the world.
And then the third law comes
in, and that's the
depressing part here.
It says, well, it's true.
If you could get to zero degrees
Kelvin, you'd get
perfect efficiency, but you
can't get to zero degrees
Kelvin, you can't.
Even if you have an infinite
amount of resources,
you can't get there.
Any questions so far?
So thermodynamics, based on
these four laws now, requires
an edifice, and it's a very
mature science, and it
requires that we define
things carefully.
So we're going to spend a little
bit of time making sure
we define our concepts and our
words, and what you'll find
that when you do problem sets,
especially at the beginning,
understanding the words and the
conditions of the problem
sets is most of the way into
solving the problem.
So we're going to talk about
things like systems.
The system, it's that
part of the
universe that we're studying.
These are going to be fairly
common-sense definitions, but
they're important, and when
you get to a problem set,
really nailing down what the
system is, not more, nor less,
in terms of the amount of stuff,
that's part of the
system, it's going to be
often very crucial.
So you've got the system.
For instance, it could
be a person.
I am the system.
I could be a system.
It could be a hot coffee
in a thermos.
So the coffee and the milk and
whatever else you like in your
coffee would be the system.
It could be a glass of
water with ice in it.
That's a fine system.
Volume of air in a
part of a room.
Take four liters on this
corner of the room.
That's my system.
Then, after you define what your
system is, whatever is
left over of the universe
is the surroundings.
So, if I'm the system, then
everything else is the
surroundings.
You are my surroundings.
Saturn is my surroundings.
As far as you can go in the
universe, that's part of the
surroundings.
And then between the
system and the
surroundings is the boundary.
And the boundary is a surface
that's real, like the outsides
of my skin, or the inner wall
of the thermos that has the
coffee in it, or it could be
an imaginary boundary.
For instance, I can imagine that
there is a boundary that
surrounds the four liters of
air that's sitting in the
corner there.
It doesn't have to be a real
container to contain it.
It's just an imaginary
boundary there.
And where you place that
boundary becomes important.
So, for instance, for the
thermos with the coffee in it,
if you place the boundary in the
inside wall of the glass
or the outside wall of the glass
and the inside of the
thermos, that makes a
difference; different heat
capacity, etcetera.
So this becomes where defining
the system and the boundaries,
and everything becomes
important.
You've got to place the boundary
at exactly the right
place, otherwise you've got a
bit too much in your system or
a bit too little.
More definitions.
The system can be an open
system, or it can be a closed
system, or it can be isolated.
The definitions are also
important here.
An open system, as the name
describes, allows mass and
energy to freely flow through
the boundary.
Mass and energy flow
through boundary.
Mass and energy --
I'm an open system, right?
Water vapor goes through
my skin.
I'm hot, compared to the air
of the room, or cold if I'm
somewhere that's warm.
So energy can go
back and forth.
The thermos, with the lid on
top, is not an open system.
Hopefully, your coffee is going
to stay warm or hot in
the thermos.
It's not going to get out.
So the thermos is not
an open system.
In fact, the thermos is
an isolated system.
The isolated system is the
opposite of the open system,
no mass and no energy can flow
through the boundary.
The closed system allows energy
to transfer through the
boundary but not mass.
So a closed system would be, for
instance, a glass of ice
water with an ice cube in
it, with the lid on top.
The glass is not very
insulating.
Energy can flow across the
glass, but I put a lid on top,
and so the water
can't get out.
And that's the closed system.
Energy goes through the
boundaries but nothing else.
Important definitions, even
though they may sound really
kind of dumb, but they are
really important, because when
you get the problem, figuring
out whether you have an open,
closed, or isolated system,
what are the surroundings?
What's the boundary?
What is the system?
That's the first thing to
make sure that is clear.
If it's not clear, the problem
is going to be
impossible to solve.
And that's also how people find
ways to break the second
law, because somehow they've
messed up on what
their system is.
And they've included too much
or too little in the system,
and it looks to them that the
second law is broken and
they've created more energy
than is being brought in.
That's usually the case.
Questions?
Let's keep going.
So, now that we've got
a system, we've
got to describe it.
So, let's describe
the system now.
It turns out that when you're
talking about macroscopic
properties of matter, you don't
need very many variables
to describe the system
completely thermodynamically.
You just need a few macroscopic
variables that are
very familiar to you, like the
pressure, the temperature, the
volume, the number of moles of
each component, the mass of
the system.
You've got a magnetic field,
maybe even magnetic
susceptibility, the
electric field.
We're not going to worry about
these magnetic fields or
electric fields in this class.
So, pretty much we're going
to focus on this set
of variables here.
You're going to have to know
when you describe the system,
if your system is homogeneous,
like your coffee with milk in
it, or heterogeneous, like water
with an ice cube in it.
So heterogeneous means that
you've got different phases in
your system.
I'm the heterogeneous system,
soft stuff, hard
stuff, liquid stuff.
Coffee is homogeneous, even
though it's made up of many
components.
Many different kinds of
molecules make up your coffee.
There are the water molecules,
the flavor molecules, the milk
proteins, etcetera.
But it's all mixed
up together in a
homogeneous, macroscopic fashion.
If you drill down at the level
of molecules you see that it's
not homogeneous.
But thermodynamics takes
a bird's eye view.
It looks pretty, beautiful.
So, that's a homogeneous
system, one phase.
You have to know if your system
is an equilibrium
system or not.
If it's an equilibrium system,
then thermodynamics can
describe it.
If it's not, then you're going
to have trouble describing it
using thermodynamic
properties.
Thermodynamics talks about
equilibrium systems and how to
go from one state of equilibrium
to another state
of equilibrium.
What does equilibrium mean?
It means that the properties of
the system, the properties
that describe the system,
don't change
in time or in space.
If I've got a gas in a
container, the pressure of the
gas has to be the same
everywhere in the container,
otherwise it's not
equilibrium.
If I place my container of gas
on the table here, and I come
back an hour later, the pressure
needs to be the same
when I come back.
Otherwise it's not
equilibrium.
So it only talks about
equilibrium systems.
What else do you need to know?
So, you need to know
the variables.
You need to know it's
heterogeneous or homogeneous.
You need to know if it's an
equilibrium, and you also need
to know how many components
you have in your system.
So, a glass of ice water with an
ice cube in it, which is a
heterogeneous system, has
only one component,
which is water, H2O.
Two phases, but one component.
Latte, which is a homogeneous
system, has a very, very large
number of components to it.
All the components that
make up the milk.
All the components that make
up the coffee, and all the
impurities, etcetera. cadmium,
heavy metals, arsenic,
whatever is in your coffee.
OK, any questions?
All right, so we've described
the system with these
properties.
Now these properties come
in two flavors.
You have extensive properties
and intensive properties.
The extensive properties are the
ones that scale with the
size of the system.
If you double the system,
they double in
there numerical number.
For instance, the volume.
If you double the volume,
the v doubles.
I mean that's obvious.
The mass, if you double
the amount of stuff
the mass will double.
Intensive properties don't
care about the
scale of your system.
If you double everything in the
system, the temperature is
not going to change, it's
not going to double.
The temperature stays
the same.
So the temperature is intensive,
and you can make
intensive properties out of the
extensive properties by
dividing by the number of
moles in the system.
So I can make a quantity that
I'll call V bar, which is the
molar volume, the volume of one
mole of a component in my
system, and that becomes
an intensive quantity.
A volume which is an
intensive volume.
The volumes per mole
of that stuff.
So, as I mentioned,
thermodynamics is the science
of equilibrium systems, and it
also describes the evolution
of one equilibrium to
another equilibrium.
How do you go from
one to the other?
And so the set of properties
that describes the system --
the equilibrium doesn't
change.
So, these on-changing properties
that describe the
state of the equilibrium
state of the system are
called state variables.
So the state variables describe
the equilibrium's
state, and they don't care about
how this state got to
where it is.
They don't care about the
history of the state.
They just know that's if you
have water at zero degrees
Celsius with it ice in, that
you can define it as a
heterogeneous system with a
certain density for the water
or certain density for the
ice, etcetera, etcetera.
It doesn't care how
you got there.
We're going to find other
properties that do care about
the history of the system, like
work, that you put in the
system, or heat that you
put in the system,
or some other variables.
But you can't use those to
define the equilibrium state.
You can only use the
state variables,
independent of history.
And it turns out that for a
one component system, one
component meaning one kind of
molecule in the system, all
that you need to know to
describe the system is the
number of moles for a one
component system, and to
describe one phase in that
system, one component,
homogeneous system, you need
n and two variables.
For instance, the pressure and
the temperature, or the volume
and the pressure.
If you have the number of
moles and two intensive
variables, then you know
everything there is to know
about the system.
About the equilibrium state
of that system.
There are hundreds of quantities
that you can
calculate and measure that are
interesting and important
properties, and all you need is
just a few variables to get
everything out, and that's
really the power of
thermodynamics, is that it takes
so little information to
get so much information out.
So little data to get a lot of
predictive information out.
As we're going on with our
definitions, we can summarize
a lot of these definitions into
a notation, a chemical
notation that that will
be very important.
So, for instance, if I'm talking
about three moles of
hydrogen, at one bar 100
degrees Celsius.
I'm not going to write, given
three moles of hydrogen at one
bar and three degrees,
blah, blah, blah.
I'm going to write it in
a compact notation.
I'm going to write it like this:
three moles of hydrogen
which is a gas, one bar
100 degrees Celsius.
This notation gives you
everything you need to know
about the system.
It tells you the number
of moles.
It tells you the phase.
It tells you what kind of
molecule it is, and gives you
two variables that are
state variables.
You could have the volume
and the temperature.
and the pressure.
But this tells you everything.
I don't need to write
it down in words.
And then if I want to tell you
about a change of state, or
let's first start
with a mixture.
Suppose that I give to a
mixture like, this is a
homogeneous system with two
components, like five moles of
H2O, which is a liquid, at one
bar 25 degrees Celsius, plus
five moles of CH3, CH2, OH,
which is a liquid, and one bar
at 25 degrees Celsius.
This describes roughly something
that is fairly
commonplace, it's 100-proof
vodka 1/2 water, 1/2 ethanol
-- that describes that
macroscopic system.
You're missing all the
impurities, all the little the
flavor molecules that go into
it, but basically, that's the
homogeneous system we were
describing, two component
homogeneous systems.
Then you can do all sorts
of predictive
stuff with that system.
All right, that's the
equilibrium system.
Now we want to show a notation,
how do we go from
one equilibrium state like
this describes to another
equilibrium state?
So, we take our two equilibrium
states, and you
just put an equal sign between
them, and the equal sign means
go from one to the other.
So, if we took our three moles
of hydrogen, which is a gas at
five bar and 100 degrees
Celsius, and, which is a nice
equilibrium state here, and we
say now we're going to change
the equilibrium state to
something new, we're going to
do an expansion, let's say.
We're going to drop the
pressure, the volume
is going to go up.
I don't need to tell you the
volume here, because you've
got enough information to
calculate the volume.
The number of moles stays the
same, a closed systems, gas
doesn't come out.
Stays a gas, but now the
pressure is less, the
temperature is less.
I've done some sort of
expansion on this.
I've gone from 1 equilibrium
state to another equilibrium
state, and the equal sign means
you go from this state
to that state.
It's not a chemical reaction.
That's why we don't have an
arrow here, because we could
go back, this way too.
We can go back and forth
between these
two equilibrium states.
They're connected.
This means they're connected.
And when I put this,
I have to tell you
how they are connected.
I have to tell you the
path, if you're
going to solve a problem.
For instance, you want to know
how much energy you're going
to get out from doing
this expansion.
How much energy are you going
to get out, and how far are
you going to be able to drive
a car with this expansion,
let's say, so that's
the problem.
So, I need to tell you how
you're doing the expansion,
because that's going to tell
you how much energy you're
wasting during that expansion.
It goes back to the
second law.
Nothing is efficient.
You're always wasting energy
into heat somewhere when you
do a change that involves
a mechanical change.
All right, so I need to tell you
the path, when I go from
one state to the other.
And the path is going to be
the sequence, intermediate
states going from the initial
state the final state.
So, for instance, if I draw a
graph of pressure on one axis
and temperature on the other
axis, my initial state is at a
temperature of 100 degrees
Celsius and five bar.
My final stage is 50 degrees
Celsius and one bar.
So, I could have two
steps in my path.
I could decide first of all to
keep the pressure constant and
lower the pressure.
When I get to 50 degrees
Celsius, I could choose to
keep the temperature constant
and lower the pressure.
I'm sorry, my first step would
be to keep the pressure
constant and lower the
temperature, then I lower the
pressure, keeping the
temperature constant.
So there's my intermediate
state there.
This is one of many paths.
There's an infinite number
of paths you could take.
You could take a continuous
path, where you have an
infinite number of equilibrium
points in between the two, a
smooth path, where you drop
the pressure and the
temperature simultaneously
in little increments.
All right, so when you do a
problem, the path is going to
turn out to be extremely
important.
How do you get from
the initial state
to the final state?
Define the initial state.
Define the final state.
Define the path.
Get all of these really clear,
and you've basically solved
the problem.
You've got to spend the time to
make sure that everything
is well defined before
you start trying to
work out these problem.
More about the path.
There are a couple ways you
could go through that path.
If I look at this smooth
path here.
I could have that path be very
slow and steady, so that at
every point along the way,
my gas is an equilibrium.
So I've got, this piston here
is compressed, and I slowly,
slowly increase the volume,
drop the temperature.
Then I can go back, the gas
is included at every
point of the way.
That's a reversible path.
That can reverse the process.
I expand it, and reverse
it, no problem.
So, I could have a reversible
path, or I take my gas, and
instead of slowly, slowly
raising it, dropping the
pressure, I go from five bar
to one bar extremely fast.
What happens to my gas inside?
Well, my gas inside is going
to be very unhappy.
It's not going stay
in equilibrium.
Parts of the system are going
to be at five bar.
Parts of it at one bar.
Parts of it may be even at zero
bar, if I go really fast.
I'm going to create a vacuum.
So the system will not be
described by a single state
variable during the path.
If I look at different points
in my container during that
path, I'm going to have to use
a different value of pressure
or different value of
temperature at different
points of the container.
That's not an equilibrium state,
and that process turns
out then to be in irreversible
process.
Do it very quickly.
Now to reverse it and get back
to the initial point is going
to require some input from
outside, like heat or extra
work or extra heat or something,
because you've done
an irreversible process.
You've wasted a lot of energy
in doing that process.
I have to tell you whether
the path is reversible or
irreversible, and the
irreversible path also defines
the direction of time.
You can only have an
irreversible path go one way
in time, not the other way.
Chalk breaks irreversibly
and you can't put it
back together so easily.
You've got to pretty much take
that chalk, and make a slurry
out of it, put water, and dry it
back up, put in a mold, and
then you can have the chalk
again, but you can't just glue
it back together.
That would not be the
same state as what
you started out with.
And then there are a
bunch of words that
describe these paths.
Words like adiabatic, which
we'll be very familiar with.
Adiabatic means that there's
no heat transferred between
the system and the
surrounding.
The boundary is impervious
to transfer of
heat, like a thermos.
Anything that happens inside of
the thermos is an adiabatic
change because the thermos has
no connection in terms of
energy to the outside world.
There's no heat that
can go through the
walls of the thermos.
Whereas, like isobaric means
constant pressure.
So, this path right here from
this top red path is an
isobaric process.
Constant temperature means
isothermal, so this part means
an isothermal process.
So then, going from the initial
to final states with a
red path, you start with an
isobaric process and then you
end with an isothermal
process.
And these are words that are
very meaningful when you read
the text of a problem
or of a process.
Any questions before we
got to the zeroth law?
We're pretty much done with
our definitions here.
Yes.
STUDENT: Was adiabatic
reversible?
PROFESSOR: Adiabatic can be
either reversible or not, and
we're going to do that probably
next time or two times.
Any other questions?
Yes.
STUDENT: Is there a boundary
between reversible and
irreversible?
PROFESSOR: A boundary between
reversible and irreversible?
Like something is almost
reversible and almost
irreversible.
No, pretty much things are
either reversible or
irreversible.
Now, in practice, it
depends on how good
your measurement is.
And probably also in practice,
nothing is truly reversible.
So, it depends on your
error bar in a sense.
It depends on what what you
define, exactly what you
define in your system.
It becomes a gray area, but it
should be pretty clear if you
can treat something is
reversible are irreversible.
Other questions, It's
a good question.
So the zeroth law we're going
to go through the laws now.
The zeroth law talks about
defining temperature and it's
the common-sense law.
You all know how.
When something hot, it's got a
higher temperature than when
something is cold.
But it's important to define
that, and define something
that's a thermometer.
So what do you know?
What's the empirical
information
that everybody knows?
Everybody knows that if you take
something which is hot
and something which is cold, and
you bring them together,
make them touch, that heat is
going to flow from the hot to
the cold, and make them
touch, and heat
flows from hot to cold.
That's common sense.
This is part of your DNA, And
then their final product is an
object, a b which ends up at
a temperature or a warmness
which is in between the
hot and the cold.
So, this turns out to be warm.
You get your new equilibrium
state, which is in between
what this was, and what
a and b were.
Then how do you know that it's
changed temperature, or that
heat has flowed from a to b?
Practically speaking, you need
some sort of property that's
changing as heat is flowing.
For instance, if a were
metallic, you could measure
the connectivity of a or
resistivity, and as heat flows
out of a into b, the resistivity
of a would change.
Or you could have something
that's color metric that
changes color when it's colder,
so you could see the
heat flowing as a changes color
or b changes color as
heat flows into b.
So, you need some sort of
property, something you can
see, something you can measure,
that tells you that
heat has flowed.
Now, if you have three objects,
if you have a, b, and
c, and you bring them together,
and a is the
hottest, b is the medium one,
and c is the coldest, so from
hottest to coldest a, b, c, --
if you bring them together and
make them touch, you know,
intuitively, that heat will
not flow like this.
You know that's not
going to happen.
You know that what will happen
is that heat will flow from a
to b from b to c and
from a to c.
That's common-sense.
You know that.
And the other way in the circle
will never happen.
That would that would give rise
to a perpetual motion
machine, breaking of
the second law.
It can't happen.
But that's an empirical
observation, that heat flows
in this direction.
And that's the zeroth
law thermodynamic.
It's pretty simple.
The zeroth law says that if a
and b -- it doesn't exactly
say that, but it implies this.
It says that if a and b are in
thermal equilibrium, if these
two are in thermal equilibrium,
meaning that
there's no heat flows between
them, so that's the definition
of thermal equilibrium, that
no heat flows between them,
and these two are in thermal
equilibrium, and these two are
in thermal equilibrium, then
a and c will be also be in
thermal equilibrium.
But if there's no heat flowing
between these two, and no heat
flowing between these two,
then you can't have heat
flowing between these two.
So if I get rid of these
arrows, there's no heat
flowing because they're in
thermal equilibrium, then I
can't have an arrow here.
That's what the zeroth
law says.
They're all the same
temperature.
That's what it says.
If two object are in the same
temperature, and two other
object are in the same
temperature, then all three
must have the same
temperature.
It sounds pretty silly, but it's
really important because
it allows you to define a
thermometer and temperature.
Because now you can say, all
right, well, now b can be my
thermometer.
I have two objects, I have an
object which is in Madagascar
and an object which is in
Boston, and I want to know,
are they the same temperature?
So I come out with a third
object, b, I go to Madagascar,
and put b in contact with a.
Then I insulate everything, you
know, take it away and see
if there's any heat flow.
Let's say there's
no heat flow.
Then I insulate it, get back on
the plane to Boston, and go
back and touch b with c.
If there's no heat flow between
the b and c, then I
can say all right, a and c were
the same temperature.
B is my thermometer that tells
me that a and c are in the
same temperature.
And there's a certain property
associated with heat flow with
b, and it didn't change.
And that property
could be color.
It could be resistivity.
It could be a lot of
different things.
It could be volume.
And the temperature then is
associated with that property.
And if it had changed, then the
temperature between those
two would have changed in
a very particular way.
So, zeroth law, then, allows you
to define the concept of
temperature and the measurement
of temperature
through a thermometer.
Let's very briefly go
through stuff that
you've learned before.
So, now you have this object
which is going to tell you
whether other things are in
thermal equilibrium now.
What do you need for
that object?
You need that object to be a
substance, to be something.
So, the active part of the
thermometer could be water.
It could be alcohol, mercury, it
could be a piece of metal.
You need a substance, and then
that substance has to have a
property that changes depending
on the heat flow,
i.e., depending on whether it's
sensing that it's the
same temperature or different
temperature
than something else.
And that property could be the
volume, like if you have a
mercury thermometer, the
volume of the mercury.
It could be temperature.
It could be resistivity, if
you have a thermocouple.
It could be the pressure.
All right, so now you
have an object.
You've got a property
that changes,
depending on the heat flow.
It's going to tell you about
the temperature.
Now you need to define the
temperature scales.
So, you need some reference
points to be able to tell you,
OK, this temperature is 550
degrees Smith, whatever.
So, you assign values to very
specific states of matter and
call those the reference points
for your temperature.
For instance, freezing of water
or boiling of water, the
standard ones.
And then an interpolation
scheme.
You need a functional form that
connects the value at one
state of matter, the freezing
point of water, to another
phase change, the boiling
point of water.
You can choose a linear
interpolation or quadratic,
but you've got to choose it.
And it turns out not
to be so easy.
And if you go back into the
1800's when thermodynamics was
starting, there were a zillion
different temperatures scales.
Everybody had their own favorite
temperature scales.
The one that we're most
familiar with is the
centigrade or Celsius scale
where mercury was the
substance, and the volume of
mercury is the property.
The reference points are water,
freezing or boiling,
and the interpolation is linear,
and then that morphed
into the Kelvin scale, as we're
going to see later.
The Fahrenheit scale is
an interesting scale.
It turns out the U.S. and
Jamaica are the only two
places on Earth now that use
the Fahrenheit scale.
Mr. Fahrenheit, Daniel Gabriel
Fahrenheit was a German
instrument maker.
The way he came up with his
scale was actually he borrowed
the Romer scale, which
came beforehand.
The Romer scale was, Romer was
a Dane, and he defined
freezing of water at 7.5 degrees
Roemer, and 22.5
degrees Romer as blood-warm.
That was his definition.
Two substances, blood
and water.
Two reference points, freezing
and blood-warm, you know, the
human body.
A linear interpolation between
the two, and then some numbers
associated with them,
7-1/2 and 22-1/2.
Why does he choose 7-1/2 as the
freezing point of water?
Because he thought that would be
big enough that in Denmark,
the temperature wouldn't
go below zero.
That's how he picked 7-1/2.
Why not?
He didn't want to use negative
numbers to measure temperature
in Denmark outside.
Well, Fahrenheit came along and
thought, well, you know,
7-1/2, that's kind of silly;
22-1/2 that's, kind of silly.
So let's multiply everything
by four.
I think it becomes 30 degrees
for the freezing of water and
22.5 x 4, which I don't know
what it is, 100 or something
-- no, it's 90 I think.
And then for some reason, that
nobody understands, he decided
to multiply again by 16/15, and
that's how we get 32 for
freezing of water and 96 in his
words for the temperature
in the mouth or underneath
the armpit of a
living man in good health.
What a great temperature
scale.
It turns out that 96
wasn't quite right.
Then he interpolated and found
out water boils at 212.
But, you know, his experiment
wasn't so great, and, you
know, maybe had a fever when
he did the reference point
with 96, whatever.
It turns out that it's not 96
to be in good health, it's
98.6 -- whatever.
That's how we got to the
Fahrenheit scale.
All right, next time we're going
to talk about a much
better scale, which is the ideal
gas thermometer and how
we get to the Kelvin scale.